hi everyone it's jerry this is game 11
from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between yan nya
pomnishi playing on the white end
and magnus carlson
going into game 11 carlson leads six and
a half three and a half in this race to
seven and a half
let's have a look
it's another e4 e5 game
no roy lopez though in this one italian
game
bishop c4
two knights variation
d3 both king bishops
out and about and some prep work for
both central and queen side expansion
d6
castles
a5
this cuts out
the queenside expansion
and produces a new square for the bishop
on a7
after rookie 1
the bishop immediately makes use of that
square
why is this why is the bishop retreating
in the first case
and y to that square of all squares
well it's retreating to duck
the d4 move with tempo we don't want to
see that hit so hard
and
why a7 rather than b6
well
on b6 it's more accessible
in what way
well here's one way
this line can surface
the knight would do well
not only hitting the bishop
but also you know it stays in this key
area of the board that's nice
additionally
if the bishop is on b6 and one day the
bishop arrives on e3 white's generating
a threat
to
damage black's queen side structure
black would like to have a different
pick
of moves
and so
it's rook excuse me bishop a7 allowing
the rook
to help defend the bishop
from here knight a3
h6
important moment
h6 if you stare at a computer line
at this stage
it'll say you can castle
but
if you castle now you have to deal with
the pin
and this pin is not easily addressed h6
right g5 that's committal
white has a choice
maybe back off or
try something like a sacrifice
what's the verdict here
murky
not
clear at all
so
probably not a good choice to allow
those complications
and so
bishop g5 is cut out all together with
h6
from here knight c2
also on the note of these kingside pawn
moves
white will want to be careful about
making this standard move h3 at this
moment
at a moment when
black is still
uncastled
if h3 is played instead of knight c2
now black can consider g5
and this can easily be very scary this
already is pretty scary for white
peeling open the g file rook g8 black
still retains the option to castle queen
side
if let's say knight c2 let me put on
some moves
this is dangerous for white
also
just a little bit ago i drew some
attention to a sacrifice on g5
would black be concerned about this
sacrifice
no
because the rook gets to make use of g8
immediately in that other variation the
king was on ga
and this pin is not really a great
bother for example h4
to try and secure the bishop well there
goes the bishop
and now there's a big big problem on f2
and it seems like white is soon going to
get mated
anyhow
careful about h3
when black is
uncastled
knight c2
castles only now
bishop e3
and have a look at the clock times
carlson spends on this next move
he spends about 14 minutes on this next
move i can assure you if the bishop was
on b6
not as much time would be spent on this
move he has a choice
instead of bishop takes bishop
he's he can consider a4 some space on
the queen side or
simple centralization looking to negate
this strong
uh this very active bad bishop
okay in the end he decides on bishop
takes bishop
and now rick to
e8 white does not allow black to grab
any space on the queen side
playing a4 himself
light square bishop exchange
b7 is now targeted it's unprotected
that's the most convenient way to defend
it simple
uh this this does leave the knight
unprotected but there isn't a great way
to take advantage of that
there is some fancy computer line
there's indirect ways you can
defend b7
well you could allow it to be captured
some 97 queen takes pawn
rook b8
some d5 move thrown in there it's
unnecessary though
b6 is simple and solid
after rook a to d1 white is well
positioned
brooks are in the center they're ready
to go the knights stand well i like the
queen
um
clearly with this last move what is
white looking to play d4 you don't play
rook a to d1 and hope the d file doesn't
open
d4 is being prepped one way or the other
knight e7
we've seen this time and time again in
this match
on the roy lopez this time now in the
italian game
this queen knight on c6
it seems like it's developed but not so
much with the pawn on c3 negating its
forward movements doesn't have any other
forward movements
so
it looks to reposition this is often a
a nice post
g6
from here h3 only now
it's not the same now white is not going
to experience any problems
uh on their king side
queen d7
and where will the break
occur
both sides are gearing up for central
play
knight g4
knight takes
pawn recaptures
this is not a deficiency for white the
doubled pawns
this knight is a convenient defender of
g4
the pawn also supports maybe a knight f5
move and white is in a position to
recapture if it is captured on f5
recapture towards the center
white can step up like this this is
healthy
a healthy structure for white
now we have some action in the center
with d5
d5 in this game is met with d4 so things
are really heating up in the center
multiple captures are available for
black in this position i do want to note
that if white goes ahead and chops away
on d5
we really do not get anywhere we would
end up in a rook specific ending
and there's not much to play for no
great targets for either side
so
d5 on board
either capture is available
carlson goes for e takes d4
and the reply is now e takes d5
now in this position if
white
captures on d4
with the rook
black recaptures or black captures on e4
with the rook
and this
doesn't go anywhere
black is only very temporarily up a pawn
and will soon win it back after queen c4
but again a pretty dry position
not much to play for here
the white knight is better than the
black knight but
yeah that's not going to be enough
so it's e takes d5
and now the reply is rook to e4 this is
considered a best move
if black captures on d5 there's going to
be a problem the light will win
this is a very serious pin
and there's not a way to get out of it
it's hit three times
it's only defended twice
c6 is met with c4 taking advantage of
the pin and if you try and defend the
knight and break the pin
now you're subjecting yourself to a
fancy night move knight f5
yeah there's this is a big problem
how do you deal with this so if rookie
six
there's now rookie to d1
once again hit three times defend it
twice same story after c6
here's one fancy variation
if rook here
you can capture like this
and then land a fork
okay it's all bad news for team black
if you capture on d5
with the knight on this move 21
it's rookie 4 in this game
preparing to meet rook takes d4
with rook takes d4
right if we have a look at this this
really is not going anywhere
knight takes d5 knight takes d5 queen
takes d5
now if this pawn was still on its home
square
this would be winning for white
because of the move rookie 8. forcing
rook takes rook
but black has the option to play king h7
and things are fine
so an important tactic right there
possibility for a deflection but it's
not there because of that
flight square
okay in this game it's queen c2
rook f4
and
a little bit of a think here right it's
about 78 minutes remaining for near palm
nishi
he spends about 10 minutes on this move
23 g3
and that's a big blunder
this knight can be captured
and it is
instead of g3
uh considered best is to go forward with
this variation it is dry but
you know you're not you're not getting
killed
at this position right here queen takes
c7 queen takes d4 major p specific all
base points covered
excellent queen post
both sides are fine equal position
something was missed here
g g3 was tried
really can't
explain it other than say it was a
blunder in the computer's eyes
a really big dip in the evaluation black
is now winning
after pawn takes knight
can afford to give up this exchange
because now the queen is sweeping in
with check
king f1 queen h3 king g1
and it's bad news for white
however you look at it
the follow-up here was a little bit
surprising to me by
black
in this position
he went with knight f5
if but black could capture on f2 here
there aren't many choices you have two
legal moves
king takes f2 would be met with the
skewer there goes the queen
and queen takes f2
could now be met with rook d6
and i don't know
what white is going to do about rook g6
f5 does not help
the knight picks it up the queen's
defending once more
this rook is getting here and
i wouldn't be surprised to see
you know after queen t
if black had played
pawn captures pawn and queen takes
and then went here
that may very well have been the final
move of this game
but it doesn't end
like that
this game continues after knight f5
white has this
uh
annoying move
d6
and this makes carlson
maybe have to he has to come up with
something else
uh
this rook isn't able to easily
assist in this attack
uh these two pieces are around and
they're dangerous enough that's for sure
but the rook isn't
going to be involved
knight h4 is the follow-up
multiple
main one threats queen g2 or knight f3
knight is really well coordinated with
the queen on h4
not many ways to defend here if queen to
e4
yeah knight f3
you have to
give up the knight like this
you're threatening this
so what's played is f takes e3
stopping this mate
knight f3 can be met
with king to f2
um
actually let me point this out knight f3
this is a good line to show
knight f3
king f2
if you play in this position
queen h2
it's not clear
surprisingly enough this is not a win
this is a way
one could go wrong
after king takes knight queen takes
queen this is a drawn position after
pawn takes pawn
this is dangerous
what are you doing about this guy
rook takes rook
and we get a queen first
with check king h7 and only then
recapture
and
even though black is up upon
uh perpetual check ideas or i'm sorry i
miscounted black isn't
black isn't even up upon in this
position
this is a drawn
uh
end game queen specific end game
so this knight f3 with the skewer idea
is not the greatest
black is still winning
after rook takes d6 but to follow up
with the skewer
as tempting as it may be this is a very
dangerous pawn
so what's tried here
it's first queen g3
after king f1 now the knight goes into
f3
so
if white tries pawn takes pawn it's a
checkmate in two
the threat here is queen g1
and queen g2 and that's a pretty neat
mate
so
we have to stop this queen g1 idea what
is white play queen f2
here's another way white can go wrong in
this position likes me black if black
captures the queen
white's winning
after king takes queen
knight takes rook
we don't recapture the knight
pawn takes pawn
white wins
rook takes rook we get the queen we
check
if rook somewhere on the back rank
we slip in we're soon going to promote
knight is way too far away from helping
so
what does black come up with here
he plays queen h3 check
two options now queen g2 king e2
let's have a look at first king e2
after king e2 now we could take the rook
and if white tries this move i've put on
a couple times now capturing on c7
black can play queen g for a check
and next take the rook
if king takes knight this is made on the
spot with either capture on d1
and if king here we take with the rook
and
we got that covered and we're ready to
make a night move and say discover check
so king e2 is no good
queen g2
now
black can capture the queen
because this knight is now able to take
on e1 in this case
with check in that earlier position the
king was on f2
so a nice little
finesse an important finesse
where exactly to have that queen
exchange
well let's invite the king on a square
where it's more vulnerable
this is what happens
and this game continues we're in an end
game now
uh
black is up a pawn
and has the more active rook
this outside pass pawn is very dangerous
when will it get rolling first
white improves the king
the rook now goes on the offensive
targeting the weak pawns
white's defensive
g6
king's ready to roll the pawn is going
to be supported soon
b4
black captures
and normally you want to meet this
capture with the recapture by a pawn you
keep the duo and you look forward to
having a pass pawn of your own
this wouldn't be a good attempt by white
if white's recapture with the pawn this
guy is weak and immediately would get
targeted
rook a2
and how this would will basically turn
out is that
black will win a second pawn
put the king on put the rook on b1
push this guy as far as you can go push
this guy as far as he could go
and it seems like these three alone will
be enough to
do the job maybe
maybe black doesn't even need the king
in this uh situation
um not 100 on that but
yeah clearly
black is now up two pawns completely
winning
two passers
so this is what white needs to avoid
uh he tries
rook takes pawn
the rook is now in a spot to watch over
these two maybe go on the offensive
from here rook a2
gives this rook a responsibility
from here it's king to e4
this king is looking to track down the
queenside pawns
uh during the live stream i
thought after rook to c4 this would have
been a
a funny variation with c5 and let's say
if the king makes a move
i believe there's a move
like f5 and you see what just happened
with that last move
this rook is dead
can't go anywhere
everything's covered
and now this pawn is ready to score a
touchdown
this rook can capture the pawn
if it tries to break down the c5 point
now this guy in the end is going to be
way too fast
anyhow rook c a rook c4 move this guy
ends up getting stuck
king e4 is tried and now the h pawn runs
rook c2
keep some pressure on the c pawn this is
the more useful pawn to capture if this
one is
uh taken then this one
is is ready to be captured
also if the rook is able to get here
it'd be supporting this base point so
it's important it's defended
continues to run
let's play out these moves right here
white now has to go on the defensive
but black has worked it out where after
he captures with check
and king takes pawn
we have
the deflection
rook takes b3
pulling the rook away so that we can now
promote and we arrive at this imbalanced
end game
queen vs rook and pawn
rook and past pawn so
you don't want this this guy to get too
far advanced
let's see
what the method is to try and win this
first centralize the queen
you can't move the pawn because we have
queen e6
this rook whenever it's unprotected it's
going to be vulnerable there's going to
be checks always in a position like this
so there's no hiding with the king
keep the rook on a secure square if you
can
in this game it's king a7 so at least if
there is a check the rook has the
opportunity to block on these
squares but the king is also in front of
the pawn so
if
eventually
uh you know eventually the king will
have to move in order for the pawn to
successfully get to
the a8 square
from here queen e7
king a8
the number one priority is track down
this pawn
you could give a check in this position
and
try and get the pawn next this is one
way to do it
but
this would be a good way for black to
lose
because of rook to b8
so
first things first some security for the
king now at least there's no rook move
with check
sidestep to that
and from here we have rook b6
if white tries
a6 here
queen e6 is excellent
pressure here
pressure there
some pressure here
and what does white do
how do you defend this guy and this guy
rook here you're going to end up losing
the rook a check
and another check
all it ever takes is just a couple moves
for a successful fork to land
so
what is tried rook v6
rook uh after queen c5 though move 49
this game goes no further
near pony she resigns
mu 49
the last move of this match
carlson takes it
winning the world chess championship for
a fifth time he has now successfully
defended his title four times against
anand
karjakin
karwana
and now nyopomnishi
what is the
move here for white there isn't a good
move
pressure on the rook and pond the only
way to defend it is this
now this pawn isn't even in a spot to
advance
and black can take some time out to pick
off the e pawn
and
the f pawn next what do you do about
that if you try and get out of the
pawn's way
this rook can return to c5 and we have a
similar story the rook would have to go
back to a6
and now we can have a couple checks and
you can see that white is getting
nowhere meanwhile this queen wiped out
those two pawns
and these guys are ready to run
no hope for team black in the end queen
c5
final move of this
2021 feed a world chess championship
match so
let's have a look at as usual
the tail of the tape on this one
there we go and we can see that it was
even steven until
this big blunder
with g3
yeah and there was
no recovering from that point on
at the end of the day nyopomnishi
won big blunder
with g3
a few inaccuracies for carlson
uh
31 and 21 for the average senti pawn
loss so
this was a fun match to cover both on
twitch twitchlivestream and
here on youtube i appreciate all your
support those of you that have been
maybe tuned in
in uh
on the stream
and on youtube or one of the two
i look forward to doing this uh whenever
that next world chess championship comes
around and i'm glad
uh my voice held up
for this championship unlike
uh
past ones so
a great
match victory for carlson really
impressive
uh four wins
two with white two with black
and a very very convincing
uh final match score seven and a half
three and a half so congrats to
carlson and a really a great fight
in buying your poem nishi those
first five six games i mean we really
got some historic games in there
uh super long game 136 move game
crazy
anyhow as usual
feel free to leave any feedback to this
video in the comments section below
i hope you enjoyed this video this match
as a whole
and
i'll catch you in the next video
that's all for now take care bye
you